this is cyberpunk running at almost
1,000 frames per second on the new RTX
590 what an absolute weapon it's three
times faster than my old 4090 at least
that's what Nvidia wants you to believe
the RTX 590 is a technological Marvel
I'm holding 92 billion transistors
alongside 32 GB of memory on the tiniest
circuit board that I've ever seen on a
flagship GPU it is just truly
mind-bending how far things have come
but it's also $22,000 this time around
so before we empty our wallets let's
take a closer look at what's happening
first a little bit of context let's
rewind a couple of years and take a look
at the 3090 versus the 4090 as you can
see it was a pretty big jump in
performance 74% to be exact in these
specific games in fact in some games the
difference is roughly double as for the
new 5090 well the upgrade is a lot more
mellow most of the games here sit around
a 30% uplift over the 4090 Red Dead
Redemption 2 saw the biggest jump of 41%
next was the new God of War at 38% there
are a couple here which seem to lack the
full GPU utilization of the 90 hopefully
those get patched soon but yeah for the
most part about a 30% uplift is what you
can expect that's a very big drop off
from the gains that we saw going from
the 3090 to the 4090 but realistically
it's still a decentish jump that will
make a difference if a 4090 is sitting
around 150 FPS or so the 5090 will now
be a lot closer to 200 normally I
wouldn't roast a GPU for only being 30%
faster than last time but here's where
things don't look so great this is the
power draw of the RTX 3090 across those
same 12 games it has a TDP of 350 wats
and it mostly sits around that level the
4090 despite having a claimed TDP of 450
wat it actually doesn't pull that much
more in most games in some games it's
actually lower than the 3090 and
remember this is while the 490 is 74%
faster on average but hold on to your
seat because this is the power increase
for the 90 apart from the couple of
games here that were just underutilized
we are seeing right around 500 wats of
power draw on average which is just
insane this is a colossal increase in
power I hope your room has air
conditioning because you are definitely
going to need it and look the only 30%
or so performance gain over the 4090 I
could honestly forgive that if the power
draw was the same or maybe a little bit
lower would be nice but man let's be
real here it's looking like there is no
efficiency gains in this new
architecture at all God of War Ragnarok
seemed to draw the most amount of power
in the games that I tested but even the
4090 just tips over 400 wats the new 590
on the other hand it's tapping right up
against that listed 575 5 W TDP it
absolutely chugs power now if you live
in the freezing cold and your PC has at
least a 1,000 W power supply then this
probably doesn't mean too much and in
that case I do have to admit 200 FPS at
4K with all settings crank to Max I mean
it is truly a beast of a GPU you won't
ever be thinking twice about what
settings to play out because you can
literally just set everything to Max
quality and still get a smooth
experience but if we have to talk about
the architect seual improvements and
power efficiency usually the number one
thing to look for in each new generation
of GPU or CPU nvidia's Blackwell is not
looking that great for some more context
here's every Nvidia Flagship GPU of the
past decade sparing the Titan gpus
notice that between the 980ti and the
2080ti there's barely any power increase
at all yet we still see respectable
performance jumps each time this new 590
on the other hand it looks a lot like
the jump between the the 2080 TI and the
3090 that was also roughly a 30% jump
for 100 WS more power this is almost the
same thing I know the FPS gained looks
bigger on this chart just because of the
way frames per second scales but the
numbers look IR really close there's one
more thing we need to discuss though and
that is multiframe Generation it's an
exclusive feature on these 50 Series
gpus and it can almost quadruple your
frame rates with multiframe Gen you can
now choose between different multiplies
2x just like the normal frame gen that
we've already seen But now 3x or 4X and
yeah you can literally play path traced
cyberpunk at 4K 240 frames per second I
want to start by saying that my
expectations for multiframe Gen were
down here they were down at the bottom
of the barrel you know I don't like the
idea of AI generated frames at all nor
do I think really anyone actually does
but I thought I'd give it an honest try
I pluged the 590 into a 4K 240 HZ
and I ran through some cyber punk I
played around with the different
multipliers had to look for the
different visual artifacts and stuff
like that and honestly every single time
I found myself wanting to play at 4X
simply because the frame rate jump was
so substantial I know it sounds like a
complete meme playing single player
games at 240 HZ but the immersion and
lifelikeness it actually does improve so
much with those extra frames but it is
not perfect and there are motion
artifacts if you look closely at the
edges you'll see some choppiness and
pixelation the more movement there is
the worse this will look and yeah I
can't lie in games where you're sitting
there observing and admiring the
graphics it's pretty easy to notice you
won't exactly be able to like pick out
and count all the little blocks but the
subtle motion Trail effect that this
leaves it is very noticeable what is way
way more noticeable though is the
difference between 80 FPS and 250 FPS if
we normalized for every other graphic
setting in the game and you're just left
with those two options I'm honestly
choosing the 250 FPS with motion
artifacts every single time I know that
sounds so weird but when you feel that
smoothness difference between those two
frame rates it is night and day
especially because the latency increase
doesn't really get much worse with those
higher frame gen multipliers with frame
gen completely off compared to cranked
all the way up to 4X it's only a 3 to 5
millisecond increase in latency which is
really really surprising and impressive
the cool thing is though if 200 FPS
gaming is really what we want to do we
don't even need frame gen to do that
even in cyberpunk at 4K we just need to
drop the graphic settings a bit to get
that smoother experience the problem
though is that you need to drop them
quite a bit we need to now use the
medium Graphics preset and all Ray
tracing needs to be switched off and as
you can see the game just does not look
the same as for the latency difference
it is pretty substantial between native
rendering and multiframe gen if you're
comparing the same frame rates and this
is the main reason that I'd never
recommend frame genen for any game
that's even mildly competitive I can't
notice by the way any artifacting with
mouse movement and camera movement which
was really great to see so if you're
exploring and looking around it actually
feels pretty decent it's the fast
driving and riding at least in cyberpunk
where those artifacts become pretty
obvious on a bike especially it's really
bad but yeah they're not real frames
after all but I don't know if I would
call call them fake frames completely
either of course they're generated but
most of the time they feel very
convincing I'm definitely glad it's an
option instead of it not existing at all
path traced cyberpunk at 240 HZ is not
something I expected to experience
anytime soon as for this tiny new little
cooler uh it's actually pretty
impressive slightly higher atts than
what I saw with a 4090 Fe but of course
with pumping a lot more power this time
around I was seeing really low 70s with
a 21° m ient room temperature and that
was with everything completely stock
pulling a little bit over 500
watts I also stress tested it in furmark
for about 30 minutes where it did pull
the full 575 Watts no problem and there
the temp settled at around 76° most of
the time though you're going to be
running at around 480 to 500 watts in
most games so expect much lower than
this but yeah it's a really impressive
little cooler so look this thing it's a
beast it's the fastest GPU at the moment
AMD has nothing that can compete with
this thing nothing even remotely close
and that's the reason that this thing is
$2,000 but at that price you've got to
be really interested in this new
multiframe gen stuff or the 32 GB of
vram for 3D or production apps for it to
start even making sense now if you're
coming from a 3090 or a 3080 then it's a
much more compelling upgrade it's like
well over double the frame rates maybe
though just pretend that the 4090 never
existed uh you could have potentially
upgraded to that a lot sooner and you
would have been getting most of the
performance that you're getting here
still a few more things that I want to
test out for this one as well as just
putting it in a really tiny case to see
how it handles that but at the very
least the 5070 and 580 are yet to be
seen so definitely stay tuned for those